hey everyone we are live here with
column shoot hey guys I'll be sent back
to stay happy st. Patrick's Day I guess
that's particularly relevant because
column grew up up gotland Ireland and he
still lives there and works as a
freelance designer their columns built a
start-up and it was acquired a couple
years ago by a company called marvel app
that works with design prototyping tools
and he's joining us now from Dublin
where he has not had too much to drink
yet he told me as I do you think well
you're very good at a carry on a
conversation bed Eddie no I can they I'm
not a pretty sober right awesome poison
well thank you for your sacrifice nobody
is thanks to you for your coherence um
column tell us a little bit about your
background my understanding is you as a
high schooler you basically dropped out
and you just focused on pursuing music
and then and after pursuit music for a
while you transition into doing design
work you tell us a little bit about that
entire era of your life yeah and so yeah
I mean I didn't really drop out of high
school but I mean I just in the last two
years I guess I didn't attend many
classes I guess you can put it that way
and so yeah I was just like really big
in the music I wasn't really getting
much out of high school didn't really
wasn't into many the topics that we were
studying Sam and I had a had a
publishing a film and TV publishing deal
with a company in la called address
choice music so I was just like you know
staying home learning trying to learn
instruments studying music theory and
just really
big into that whole world and my school
my high school didn't offer music so it
was just like inaccessible there so and
so yes when I spent like six years and
just studying music non-stop I'm trying
to trying to make it in that hole you
know industry but I I got to a point
where I hit a wall kind of it's just
like music and industry is funny it's
kind of it's really locked down you know
when you get to a certain point it's
just so hard to like push through and go
take it further you really have to like
move to LA and like in you know really
start building connections and things
like that like going to auditions and
stuff like I mean I guess my ultimate
goal was to like become a session
musician of some sort like play guitar
you know in studios and like you know
tour with some type of it alive act make
money that way but it's just so
competitive so tough unlike in in terms
of songwriting and things like it's
really locked down there's like an inner
circle of songwriters that just right
all pop music and it's hard to break in
so yeah eventually I kind of you know
became disheartened with that and wasn't
really sure what I wanted to do and my
dad had an had a print company just a
very small print shop in my hometown and
excuse him and his business partner so
he just asked me one day that I want to
come down and check it out so I went
down and he gave me one of those old a
mobile imax and just shot me not in a
dark corner and in the background and
just like gimme like some cracked copy
of illustrator and just like just just
let me let me out it you know and I I
just fell in love like straight away
just became completely enamored with the
whole world of design you know I had no
idea what I was doing at all wasn't even
sure like what the various paper sizes
were like a tree and a-two a-one etc and
but yeah I worked there for like four
years with them you know just learned
everything and you know just off the
coast just like took a flyer or poster
and tried to copy an illustrator try to
recreate things business cards and you
know
learned everything about print industry
and and then you know after after 44
years or four and a half years there and
I I got into web design true and what
was the problem was he wasn't like a
WYSIWYG editor freeway that was that's
what it was called was like a don't
you've heard of it yeah freeway it's
kind of like and it was like dreamweaver
you know back in the day it was like a
WYSIWYG editor wait you could like
drag-and-drop elements to create a
website and then you know deploy it live
without writing without writing any code
at all and so that's that's how I like
transition into web design and and then
my brother who my brother was a program
at the time he's two years older than me
so he was he was constantly pushing me
to to write to learn HTML and CSS you
know I have in one of my websites that
built with freeway I'd have liked some
issue and I go ruin to him and ask him
how can he fix it and he'd be like Oh
David I can't I can't even read this
code you know yeah those apps was
garbage ugh yes I mean I had no idea
what I was handing him but it was just
like here trying to fix this and so yeah
he was like constantly pressuring me to
learn code and eventually you know I
just just learned some HTML CSS online
and they then left a print shop was
working for and went out on my own
freelancing awesome and you're
freelancing career ultimately transition
into building a product yeah well many
products I gotta head a bit like five or
six or more probably startups yeah with
my brother most of my brother and yeah
we had no ideas like this is going back
seven eight years ago you know we were
just like one of them we tried to build
a an app for for like a rental app you
know for for buying for renting or
buying houses we were just using rails
you know my brother was a rails
programmer and you know we just tried to
get taco he tried to get something going
for their prince
close working at it was like Trello but
just for print for the print industry
and yet try a bunch of things and they
all just failed miserably and and then
just see how one day I mean I was
realized freelancing there 10 for a few
years you know just various clients and
building startups on the side and yeah I
started plexi which was a design tool
which was a web based design too so it's
kind of like sketch but like and you
know no way it's like much more simpler
you know much more simpler than sketch
and I was in the browser and it was I
tried to focus on animation like
interaction based design and so yeah I
mean I built the first version it out on
my own with my extremely limited
JavaScript skills and just like put a
really really rough prototype on
designer news and it did well like you
know a lot of people took interest and a
lot of people emailed me about it and
courage me to keep working on it and so
yeah cap work on our for like two years
I hired a guy in a call Elliot in New
York he was like he was about 18 at the
time yeah really amazed me like how he
had like he had a really high reputation
on Stack Overflow for like answering
javascript programming questions that's
how I found him he was just like a
genius to know just everything I would
just give him like a bunch of tasks in
shallow that I that I couldn't I
couldn't do and like you know the next
week he would just have them all gone
completely you know perfect like so that
ought to was felt like a year and a half
or two years working on on plexi and
getting it to a point where what we
could release it on a then I released it
and it just kind of went dead you know
so and that was kind of turning but I
mean we spent like six months yeah or
like I mean I wasn't working with Elliot
then after that but I on my own I spent
like six months trying to like improve
it and continuing to develop it and I
like talking with some customers who
still using it for them the overall it
was just like really hard to get
traction and you know retain users
because like that whole industry is so a
competitive you know there's so many
prototyping tool is coming at every
other day and then eventually just out
of the blue a more apt for marvel app
reached out to me and said that they
were thinking about building a similar
tool and put like router and start from
scratch that they would just acquire
plexi and I'm bring this on board so
that was really cool so that's what
happened then yeah well tell us a little
bit about the acquisition process I
would imagine a lot of the developers
and designers who are watching this
haven't actually been acquired like this
that's like a very few startups required
it's probably like maybe it two percent
or something of them actually make it to
that level so what was that process like
of being having your product integrated
into marvel app and joining the marvel
app team yeah i mean that was that was
really cool the whole thing was
completely new to me because i guess
like the best part about it was that was
validation you know it was like because
right up until that point I had no idea
what I was you know I had no idea if I
was in the right track or if I wasn't
you know I guess I was just like
everyone else just like just working
away slugging away and trying to learn
new skills and I'm not really seeing
anything come of it you know unless of
course if you're working for a job
thought I him then when we like when
when my startup got acquired it was like
wow maybe I am doing something right you
know and so yeah that was cool me the
guy ate the guys are marble acquired
then start up and then brought me on
Elliot on board together like I was
working with in New York so the two was
set join the team of Marvel and spent
about a year and a half there
integrating plexi into their platform
and which is now called canvas Marvel
canvas and I mean it's been raped since
that has been rebuilt from the ground
look in a in canvas and in location
modified canvas and with the guys on
board like with like an rebuilt and
react and so yeah that's cool awesome so
they took your prototype or I guess
you're fully functioning app and use it
as kind of a prototype for the full
refactor to react app exactly exactly I
mean initially it was released as a beta
and on its mean it was kind of like as a
test initially I guess the first launch
to see let's see what people be
interested in this it was because marvel
Martha way marble app works is that n
you upload images like you design your
screens in sketch or Photoshop and then
upload images and then you can piece
them together using marble apps platform
and so marvel canvas was like the first
step toward having an in-house like a
built-in way that you can draw your own
images net and so I mean I the guys are
still developing that and I believe that
they're pretty pretty close to their
first release awesome we can we can
definitely look for that in the future
so you went from just to recap you went
from a high school student who was
primarily focused on learning music
music theory composition you did that
for a number of years then you did
graphic design I guess working with
print and learning that aspect of design
and then you transition into web design
and you learn to code and then you built
a product you felt many products but one
of them was acquired and you worked on
that for two years and now you're
working as a freelancer and you wrote an
amazing extremely popular medium article
recently about the notion of Design
Systems and I've linked to it below for
anybody who hasn't read this article you
should absolutely check out columns
article but can you describe what a
design system is real quick and perhaps
contrast it to a design framework for
example a CSS framework yeah m yeah I'm
you know I've been going back and forth
various definitions I'm not reassuring
myself what exactly the best way to
describe it but in my article I said
design system is an evolving set of
rules governing the composition of a
product so it's like it's basically
everything from your your palates you
like your color palettes you know
shadows all the the values that you
apply to the properties that make up you
know the styles that make your company
look like your company and not like
other companies and you know coupled
with the components that you have like
buttons and inputs which would be your
UI toolkit I guess and coupled with like
him you know larger components and
encompass it like screen compositions
and plus like code guidelines and you
know naming conventions for files and
I'm for the code I guess and plus like
rules like a 44 like when to use this
button when to use that input went
eustis heading and when not use this
font size and you know rules that like
that govern how your developers and
designers should compose screens you
know using using your code base and
using your design and and and that
applies like a cross-platform you know
not just on web not just a mobile put
like you know on your entire suite of
products so yeah I mean that's that's
what I mean at least when I say design
system so really the design system is
like the central document that governs
all the other design documents it's like
the master design document yeah i guess
i guess you put it on you yeah and do
you know of any organizations that have
this kind of like master plan for design
that they've actually taken it to that
level where they're coming full systems
design thinking and I mean honestly it's
like it's very very rare I mean I
mentioned in my article that design
systems are becoming much more popular
and which is great to see I mean
everyone there are tons and tons of art
is about design systems are like tons of
people linking to books and resources by
Design Systems lots of job post lots of
companies are posting job listings like
unsetting a team specifically for a for
design systems design system rolls and
but in terms of like like seeing
products that are you know rolled out
with like complete completely integrated
design systems that are up to date it's
very rare even see them and I guess like
best examples would be Google Google's
material design which is like a super
super comprehensive design a system a
guidelines and another great example
would be Airbnb and yeah they did tons
and tons of work on design systems and
designs just from tooling I believe
they've got an in-house team and
specifically for Design Systems so I
mean yeah that's another company and
their company will be intercom who are
ya as far as I'm aware they're just
setting up a design systems team but
they really I chatted with with some of
the guys and intricate intercom and I
mean there really seem to understand the
importance of design systems and like
how and they really like how you know
how important it is to to approach
design in a systemic way you know
writers were just like sporadically but
like things like even things like 20
kids like a foundation or bootstrap you
know even though they have like
bootstrap has like comprehensive
documents on how to how to work with the
bootstrap toolkit but you know it's not
it's not coded or designed in a really
systematic way like for example take the
bottom component and like it displays
the button component it shows what it
should look like and it shows you how to
use it in code but it doesn't go as far
as to say like how you should this point
and look on a dark background or you
know on a blue background it doesn't it
doesn't take into account the actual
pragmatic uses of design system you know
when you actually go to build a website
you know almost a hundred percent of
websites
we'll have some alternate background
color and each of your components should
be able to function on that background
color you know if they are supposed you
know some component should never be used
on it certain background color and and
if you look at various websites like him
not to i don't wanna be not in anyone's
worked for like it and I was like oh
yeah if you want like open the kids
start I'll just thinking it I hope and
marcado works again hope on people to
extrapolate that they recently rolled
out a new header and you know of like a
dark knob and I was looking at was
looking at CSS and it's like they've
styled the input a specific to the dark
header so it's like elsewhere in the
code base they've said here's what our
input looks like but in this specific
location we're going to hack it to make
it look something like differently
because it's on a different color
background and we didn't think about
that earlier on we're designing our
design system so I think like that's for
me that's like the essence of Design
Systems thinking and like everything you
do stop for a second before you do it
and think where exactly will this
component be used and how would it be
used and like I wanted it it's not going
to be using just one way you know we
need to consider all the different ways
that this component is going to be used
yeah so in many ways it's it's just a an
extension of design thinking and systems
engineering kind of concepts the notion
that you should slow down and think in a
whole system's way whenever you're
making a change so that you don't end up
with a whole lot of bolted on
functionality and a lot of yeah one off
stuff yeah yeah yeah I like I mean did
the thinking is when you're doing
one-off change the thinking is oh it's
just a one-off but like if you look at
ninety percent the code bases they're
like they're just made up of tons of
one-off changes yeah there's always that
that joke about of like this is
temporary or sort of like that like in
and you look at history and it's from
like years ago any code changes as
though they're gonna live on forever net
I mean look if you look at like
Microsoft's all talking terms of code
that's what I know but if you look at
like Microsoft Windows
for example the reason the codebase just
huge you know bigger and bigger and
every release is like an extra gigabyte
or two is because they're worried about
breaking stuff and changing stuff so
instead it just it just creeps and for
example a function that would normally
take like two parameters has these other
20 parameters nobody's brave enough to
remove them yeah exactly yeah I mean you
see that all the time yeah yeah and CSS
I guess so you let's step back and talk
a little bit about how you research
these things because it sounds like you
spent a lot of time just going and
looking at websites and inspect element
and digging into the CSS it's sad sad
but that's most of my life so it do you
think an extension of your kind of
self-taught ethos you know you learn
music on your own you learn design on
your own without formal training
certainly not formal academic training
you think that's just kind of a
reflection of how you learn I definitely
think so I think so because I'm not sure
I'm not sure if I gravitated towards
those same those industries are those
types of jobs because of some innate
personality trait I have or because I
gained this in a personality trait from
working in like so many of these types
of jobs I'm not sure which which way it
went put it but certainly there are tons
of parallels for example between like
the workout data music and the work I do
now in design for example and like
distilling distilling down a song like
into tiny little snippets of music and
and then it's like storing them so I can
you know I can refactor them until
they're perfect you know nothing's ever
perfect bill until I'm until I'm happy
with them and then like reusing them
throughout the song and onyx exact same
with code you know like like you're
stilling down at you are into tiny
little reusable components and even
further down into tiny little reusable
styles and you know refract on those
until they're perfect and then we're
using them tread the whole UI m
oh yeah and sorry what was the question
I just hung off we were just kind of
riffing on the nature is it a reflection
of the way you learn yeah it's ad hoc
like let's yeah I mean I guess in the
real world and and I mean that is how i
learned initially I just them like even
in print that's how I learned I we just
take a poster and I was just try and
copy the poster and but like when I was
learning web design I remember like
going to Facebook and trying to copy
their their blue heron out and you know
and I would just I would just inspect
element for ages i can try and copy the
color and then try and rebuild myself
without having facebook open so yeah i
mean that's that's like a huge part of
how i learned just just like drilling
away at something until it was perfect
and I mean I guess that's why that's
that's that's why I went so deep in the
design systems because constantly when I
was when I was building websites and I
would just constantly run into this
problem where I you know designed my
import component for example and like
thought it was perfect and then when I
actually went to build a number of
different screens with that you are
component I would always have to tweak
it and change it and like hack it into
place like to make you know some margin
fit or resize it for a sidebar or you
know change the background color to put
it into a header knob or and I always I
just got to wondering like I'm adding
something wrong here or like is this
wallet like all websites do and it turns
out that that is how most websites
handle it they just hacking at the place
but I just always thought like it was
something I was missing and I finally
realized yeah like I mean I was just
doing half the work all the time I was
just in half the work and then like
neglecting the whole like neglecting the
other half of the work and all my
components were like only build fifty
percent they were just build for a white
background and that was it and I had no
actual I wasn't I wasn't baking in any
understanding of how these components
will be used in a real world I was just
coding them for like so they looked good
on dribble or something you know
so mania I mean definitely well I
understand that you're working on a new
project right now I think you mentioned
that you're working on so sort of CSS
framework or tool yeah yeah it's called
anthem no for better or worse what's it
called phantom phantom okay yeah what
does bantam mean is that like a mound I
hate naming things so badly but it it's
you know bantamweight you know like you
know the fight weight divisions ah
that's where I've heard that before I
don't wait or bantamweight or
heavyweight you know so it's like I name
the Bantam because like pontem is really
lightweight division and at the time
years ago when i started it i was i was
just trying to like him bill the
smallest set of reusable style classes
that i could build that i could just use
to build almost any website and it
weighed like you know three or four
kilobytes after compression and so I
call it Bantam Wow since since then it
has evolved into a full-blown to cook it
so it's not so bad them anymore but it's
I mean I'm not changing the name cuz i
hate naming things that's a good name
it's very I mean I didn't know what aunt
away was but now that you explained it
didn't excellent synonyms for
lightweight which it sounds like that
was certainly one of the goals is just
performance and not being a heavy tool
like bootstrap keeps getting bigger and
bigger for example all out of the other
popular frameworks are getting bigger
and bigger I mean how do you prevent so
one of the things we've been talking
about is the fact that you're doing like
when you just build the component
without thinking of the context is going
to be used and you're really only doing
half of the work you're always going to
be encountering corner cases that you
need to update your entire design system
to reflect and compass how do you keep a
tool lightweight when you know that
there's going to be that kind of
evolutionary trial and error process
yes so I've been right now I'm in the
midst of building a bathroom and trying
to get ready for v1 and and what I'm
doing is just taking each component one
at a time and I'm I have like a test
couple of test em screens so I'm
building like a really complex email
screen you know something like a mailbox
was you know em and I've got a marketing
a screen that I'm building out and I've
got another like statistics based web
app screen of building it so I'm every
time I I make some petition progress on
on one of the components I tested out in
these screens in each of these
screenings and I make sure that it a it
fits and it works in all in each of the
different contexts that it's going to be
using eventually and I mean obviously
these these three strains world
encompass every single use case for all
of these components but I mean I'm never
gonna you know be able to solve
everyone's problems so am I mean I mean
I'm happy I'm happy with just testing it
in those three screens and so it's like
you know those those three different
screens have different colored
backgrounds they have like sometimes it
opponent is in a sidebar sometimes it's
in a knob sometimes it's in your main
content and sometimes like an input is
coupled with a button sometimes an input
has an icon inside it there's just so
many different variations on each
component and as I'm building at the
pages I'm going back to the component
stand here like you know make sure that
they that all these same context are
baked into the component how soon do you
think you'll have like a alpha release
of the people can play with yeah I mean
well people could start playing right
now it's on there it's on github bantam
and i have it on NPM and i have it
hosted on s3 so you could start playing
and play around with it right now but
it's a [ __ ] I mean obviously it's
heavily in flux but I'm hoping to have
like v1 ready in maybe three weeks four
weeks
something awesome and so once you have
that be one out is are you going to try
to keep the name spacing consistent so
that it doesn't like so you don't break
backward compatibility for future
versions or is that is that a concern or
are you just going in or going to be I
mean I haven't dishes like this would be
my first day I mean this is my first
open source project that I mean was
taking any interesting I mean only has a
hundred stars and github but it's like
infinitely more than anything else I've
ever worked on and so I don't have too
much experience working open open source
projects and how even contributed to
many open-source project so i'm not i'm
not entirely sure exactly how it works
or what but what the best practices are
but from what i gather just from reading
some articles on it and i don't think i
want to be too concerned with versioning
and because it just becomes this
nightmare of like you know dealing with
support question things like that right
and i think i think like that i think
after I release the v1 the next a step
would be to ported to react and and like
maybe using CSS modules or stall
components or something like that but
after that i guess like the main changes
for in each version would just be visual
you know like updating the components so
that they they you know they look modern
no so the whole frame it doesn't end up
looking really dated you know aside from
that I can't imagine changing Tim watch
at least I'm hoping not to have to
change too much I guess I guess we'll
find a yeah I mean that's a good problem
to have a whole lot of people are using
your product in and gives you good for
sure oh I'm going to recommend everybody
who's watching this read that article
again that you wrote about design
systems you should all follow column on
Twitter and check out his personal
website which i discovered is hosted on
net lafai which is a pretty cool new
static page hosting service that like
that
and I'm going to also put a link if you
have a link to your github repo i'll put
a link into the the notes below in as
soon as we in the stream and everybody
go check it out if you think it's cool
give it a star cool well thank you so
much a column for taking time out of
your st. Patrick's Day Friday evening no
problem thank you thanks for having me
Sloan yeah it was a pleasure and I'm
looking forward to hearing updates on
how bantam goes and and I'm very excited
too if you get a chance to write about
it I'd love to read it and I think our
community would love to read about the
evolution of this framework as well yeah
yeah lots of articles plan then she have
some fun to write some something you
still funny after its release all right
well thank you again have a beautiful
weekend thank you everybody for tuning
in and keep keep working on that man
we're very excited to see it cool thanks
guys here's everyone